(Yelling) Oh god it's so hot!!
Oh, I'm gonna start sweating, it's gonna be ridiculous.
I gotta take my pants off. You guys can't see this, right? *says that in front of the camera recording his pants*
you guys cant see this Probably
Ahh, shit. I'm not wearing underwear.
Alright, now that that emergency is taken over, let's get back to the vlog!
(Wacky laughing)
So hello. Hi! I'm Markiplier!
But you knew that! But maybe you didn't because you didn't see me yesterday!
I took a day off, which is something that I don't often do.
In fact, I can't remember th-the last time that I did the thing that-that is.
So in case you've forgotten me, my name is Mark and I do YouTube videos online.
Uh, the reason I took a day off and this is something that I very rarely do,
But the reason is probably obvious; I was losing sleep
I had too much work piling up, I was getting behind on videos
I was waking up...at 5:30 every day to get videos done for an 8 A.M release
So, you can imagine, that, as time goes on, when you're going to bed at like 11 and midnight
And you're getting up at 5:30 it's like, a military schedule and it's not good for you and you're gonna die eventually
And probably have heart failure and gray hairs are going to sprout all over my face 'cause I'm old
(Sobbing) And I'm desperately trying to hold onto my youth!
Being 27 years old is really getting to me
I'm already over the hill...to you young millennials it may not seem that old, but when you get up to my age (raspy voice) it's old!
So anyways, I-I really am grateful that you guys were so understanding of me taking a day off
And I do appreciate that. I don't do it often and I don't like to do it often because I love to work!
It's weird, I like working!
Especially because the work that I do is so fun.
Uhh but the main reason is yesterday I had to work on this script
And it's been staring at me in the face for so long and like, Sunday was the deadline, I had to get it done
I had to dedicate like six hours just to writing and I got it done! It's totally cool, and what else I managed to do is I managed to catch up
on recording videos
(Deep Mark breath with nose)
Uh so that you guys can have enough content on a regular basis and I don't have to keep scrambling to record in the morning, and then edit in the morning
(Deep gravely voice) And then do everything else in the morning.
And then fall asleep and pass out at 4 P.M
Wake up, DRINK MYSELF TO DEEATH
Either way, I'm fine and everything is good now
I got the script done; it's for that-uh-this project that I've been hinting at for ever and ever and ever
(Mark Inhale)
Uhh, there's a lot of cool things going on with it, it should be happening very soon
But it's finally done, and now I can focus on the  more important things in 'muh channel!
Which is this stuff that I really care about, and I'm really grateful that you guys are so understanding
In times like this where I am unfortunately just, I'm one guy!
I'm one guy! I'm editing my own stuff again!
I'm-I'm just doing everything by myself, so it's very hard for me, as a one-man-army, with so many things to tackle, to do it all by myself
But i'm grateful f- to do it, but I'm human and have HUMAEHN limbs, I have HUMAEHN needs
I'm an old man... (Sobbing)
So just thank you everybody so much for being so understanding
AND I have another question that's going to sound really conceited
And (while laughing) is another example of an old guy trying to hold on to his youth so desperately.
Is, whether I should dye my hair back red.
Because I've got enough of my natural black coming out
(Inhale)
That I could possibly redye it again and I could keep the red going
Because it's kinda weird with how much faded it is and
And strewn out from my natural hair colors
So, I-I DID want to get you guys' opinion,
Because the red is really nice; I LOVE the red.
Don't get me wrong
I LOVE the red, I wanna keep the red
Even though I'm staining every clothe article that I have with RED
And all my towels are SPEWED with red,
As if I murdered 10 million people in my house.
Which I didn't(suuure)
But I just wanted to get you guys' opinion and here the reasons why it's a dilemma.
I don't MIND keeping the red. I really don't.
But, it's a weird thing, because now I-I've reached this weird point
Where by- I'm being like, offered, roles in other things outside of YouTube.
And I don't know if I want to dedicate my time to that
But a lot of the things that they request
Is that I...
DYE my hair back to a normal color, because colored hair,
IN ACTING,
Is a very, specific, stereotype.
And you-you get stereotyped a lot in real acting
And it's like, if your character has colored hair,
He's a certain type of person and he does this thing in this way,
Where as,
Here, on YouTube, I get to be ME.
And, my inclination is just to follow what I like,
And, follow what I want, because YouTube has always been about what I do,
So, that's why I wanted to get your opinion on it because you're just as much apart of this channel as I am,
So, what do you guys think?
Do you think I should go for red again? R-r-r-or not?
Also it dawns on me that this video is probably going to be late so I apologize for that.
Yesterday was NOT for nothing, this was for a reason. I was just working out this morning,
Because I've been trying to be healthy all year,
And I've been doing a great job as you can see
I've been getting some sweet results bruuhh
BRUUUHHHHH
(pterodactyl scream)
But enough about that, enough about the silliness,
Uh, the main reason that uh, I wanted to...
Make this vlog today, uh was because I've been...
Trying to get more involved in the community,
I'm trying to keep up with everything because there is so many people now
That it's hard to stay in touch
Uh, with all the different social media platforms and it's hard to follow along for everything,
So, I've been trying to make, like, effort of doing that
A-and one of the common things that I've seen,
Obviously, and this is like, a pervasive topic throughout the entirety of the internet, is
Hate.
On the internet, and what hate means and how you deal with hate,
And what hate represents, w-when it's coming AT you on the internet.
And, a lot of people ask me like how I deal with it
Considering I am like the lightning conduit of HATE on the internet
And... I'm totally fine with that. I don't mind it at all.
Uh, because...when I started on YouTube obviously when my first, video,
Uh, i-it went like "viral" on reddit, it got like number 3
Uh, th-the Amnesia Reaction Compilation got like number 3
On the video section of reddit, and it was like,
The 10th video, I ever made,
And so, that was my first exposure to like, a WIDE audience,
And suddenly... I was getting SO many subscribers and it was great,
It was like, my channel was just EXPLODING,
This was like, tens, of subsribers
But my channel was exploding in MY eyes, and it was SO amazing,
But then at the same time, came in the first influx of HATE.
And I'd NEVER experienced internet hate before in my LIFE.
And, what was weird was, at first I was like
(high pitched voice) Oh.
(high pitched voice) They don't know me.
(high pitched voice) Oh no! I gotta convince them that I'm COOL.
So I, like, (laughing) I would like, message people, directly, being like,
(high pitched voice) Hey. Um... Uh, you're entitled to your own opinion but I justed to let you know
I'm a COOL guy.
(sobbing)
And, obviously, that didn't get the response I warranted
(laughing) It just meaned that I gave them more ammo
With which to throw back at me.
A-and that like, crafted my philosophy on how I deal with hate
Uh, (muffled) on the internet
And most of it, is just...
You gotta ignore the majority of it,
Because the majority of it is just mindless hate.
Coming from nowhere, from people trying to poke bears
Wherever they can poke, and they get joy out of getting response
And that's, fine, that's the internet, that's life,
But... when that comes AT you, a lot of people don't know how to deal with it
Because, uh-like because you guys are good-natured people.
MOST people are good-natured people, and, it's WEIRD that someone would randomly want to throw hate at you
So the natural inclination is to try to fix the problem,
Which is an admirable response,
I don't DIMINISH that response in any way,
Uh, but as far as my advice goes,
If you do that, if you don't, it doesn't matter
It's whatever you choose to do
But, my mindset when I approach hate IS...
These people
The, anonymous hate on the internet, they don't know who YOU are as a PERSON.
They don't know the experiences that YOU have been through individually.
They don't know what you've gone through.
They don't don't know the pain of your life.
They don't know the JOYS of your life.
They know next to NOTHING, except what you have PUT,
Which is a narrow sliver of your life on the internet.
So... that, narrow, image is all they base their hate on.
And therefore, they don't actually KNOW you.
And therefore, they don't have any RIGHT,
To HATE,
On You. Your life isn't influence by that at ALL.
Because, they don't understand who you ARE.
Now, if this was coming from a FRIEND,
If I got a friend of mine,(if)
That came up to me and told me I was a HORRIBLE person and I was just being awful,
And what I was doing was wrong,
And I should just GIVE up, and GO home and not do it EVER again.
THAT would affect me, like that would affect me because MY friends,
and the people that I keep in my life, are people that I TRUST.
Very much so. And that trust means I trust their opinion.
(yelling) BUT ANONYMOUS PEOPLE ON THE INTERNET?
(yelling) FUCK 'EM, WHO GIVES A SHIT!
(laughing) THEY'RE NOBODY, exactly nobody,
Especially if they're anonymous.
Now, I-I'm not diminishing internet friends at all,
You can have internet friends and people that you trust on the internet.
And you would value their opinion just as much as anything else,
(increasing voice) BUT WHEN IT COME TO THE RANDOM, SPEWING,
(flailing hands) TOXIC, VENOM, THAT PEOPLE ARE THROWING AROUND, I couldn't GIVE a shit
About that. It means NOTHING.
Because... I make my videos, for anyone who wants to make my videos,
I do my things for anyone that wants to,
I don't MAKE IT FOR them, they are ALLOWED to not like my videos,
They are allowed, to take THAT, and keep it with themselves, because I honestly,
Am OKAY with them not liking my videos, I'm honestly okay with them not enjoying what I put in front of them
Because that's the narrow sliver that they SEE.
And if they disagree with that narrow sliver,
THAT'S TOTALLY FINE!
I AM 100 PERCENT OKAY WITH THAT!
(yelling) THEY CAN DO WHATEEEVER THEY WANT.
Like seriously. They are their own person.
Even though they may seem from an anonymous perspective, like they're just a random,
(deep voice) Somebody. But they're a random whoooever. I-it really doesn't matter.
So, they're allowed... to take whatever small view they have of you,
And I'm not saying they're narrow-minded, a lot of them are, but I'm not saying they are.
I'm saying they only see... a part of you...
So you can either try to show them all of you,
And most likely they won't listen but,
You can try to show them all of you,
Or, you can try to keep putting out the best of you, possible.
And that best of you is the best that you can possibly make the best that you can possibly do right now,
That is the best you're doing.
And you do that every day and eventually,
You'll start to find people, that do enjoy... that, sliver of who you are.
And when they enjoy that,
Then they wanna know more, and then they open themselves up
And you open yourself up to them, and its just kind of like...
I don't know.
That's how friends are made.
That's how people get to know each other, that's how people really make bonds, is that,
They see things that they agree with,
And hopefully doesn't turn into a big circle jerk but they see things that they agree with,
And they're like, Okay...
Maybe I can trust this guy.
Maybe I can... see what this girl's all about.
Maybe I can see what they're creating an-
I kinda like it.
And that's like the start of something beautiful
And that's... the, philosophy that I've taken through for my channel.
So... that's pretty much all I wanted to talk about; It got rambly again as I always do,
But, hopefully that made sense to some of you as far as it comes to hate,
On the internet.
And I know I'm not an ADVICE guy.
But that's just my experience with it and how I've dealt with it over the years.
So, take that for what you will; I hope that helps somebody out there,
And THANK YOU everybody so much for watching,
I think I've covered about everything. This Friday we'll be doing-
Oh no. This SATURDAY, we'll be doing the charity livestream, I will be going BACK to Cincinnati,
And joining Wade,
For a FUN time, for charity, so remember write your suggestions for the charity down in the comments below,
I'm gonna be reading from the last vlog as WELL.
And picking the-
I'll try to get my, uh, pick for tomorrow, so write literally whatever charity you want,
Get a highly rated, highly reputable charity, and let me know what you want to raise for, so,
THANK YOU AGAIN EVERYBODY SO MUCH FOR WATCHING, AND ALSO,
Write suggestions for challenges we can do
(chuckle) in the livestream as well.
THE MORE PAINFUL THE BETTER, because (laughing) I wanna see Wade suffer
Ohhh *malevolence increases
I'm so malicious like that, but thanks again everybody so much for watching,
AND AS ALWAYS. I will see YOU... In the next video.
(Mouth Click) BUH-BYE!! (Thank the subtitle people for typing this god damn it)